welcome to Bab District Council planning
committee um I will now ask the
governor's officer to read out the
domestic arrangements and the fire
regulations CLA thank you thank you
chair
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use please do not
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations While others are
speaking if you're intending attending
the meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave please ensure your mobile
phones are on silent or switched off and
that your laptop is also switched to
syum I'd like to remind everyone present
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded by
entering this meeting as a speaker you
will also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sounds recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes the
council members of the public and the
Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not openly excluded if
you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately via a fire exit and
make your way to the assembly point
which is Ipswich toown football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exit which is behind
you do not enter the
atrium use the stairs not the lifts and
do not re-enter the building until sold
is safe to do so thank you chair thank
you CLA make some introductions we have
with us today the area planning manager
Mr Mark
Russell we have our legal advisor I de
prey we have our case officers and vo if
I pronounce that correctly I thank you
and Elizabeth flood with our governance
officer you already met CLA
Philpot can I move to the agenda please
thank you do you have any apologies for
absence yes chair we have apologies from
councelor Davies and councelor Busby is
substituting councelor Holt and councel
clover is substituting apologies from
councel mabery and councel Reese is
substituting and apologies from councel
Wyman councilor Pary is
substituting BL
me at least it's the veterans returning
isn't it Lance thank
you Declarations of disclosable
pecuniary interest and other
registerable non-registered interests by
members are there any to
declare am I switched on I I will just
mention that you you you Mr chairman
very sensibly asked my advice early in
the week and I believe it's the
applicant in the Bentley case happens to
be an organization that you're the
parish council that you're your chairman
of which has no business in this
committee today uh had some dealings
with and my my advice is that that you
well I'll discuss with the officer my
colleagues whether anything needs to go
in the minutes but my advice is that you
don't have any interest to clear or any
worry and it doesn't I think applying
the common sense and common law test of
bias I don't think it crosses the
threshold so we we we will if you feel
comfortable we'll
proceed thank you very
much any other
declarations any Declarations of
lobbying
no Declarations of personal site
visits no right moving on confirmation
of the meeting held on the 29th of
November
[Music]
apologies
chair my boss misled
me what should that be the 18th of
October the 18th of
October
right are there any points of regarding
the accuracy of these minutes and more
accurate than my
notes
nope um right in that case could I have
a proposer please to accept them Adrien
Osborne a second please councelor Tim
register electronic vote thank
you thank you chair so that vote is
reading correctly as the 18th of October
and it's now in
progress councilor beer can I take your
vote please thank you
councilor Reese have you managed to log
in oh okay can I take your vote then
please you so you abstaining are you
thank
you
thank you chair that's eight votes eight
votes for and three extensions thank you
thank you minut have been
accepted
okay sign after the
meeting any notification of
petitions Namy chair thank you site
inspections any
requests no requests no requests thank
you moving
to the schedule of planning
applications um we start off with DC
652 land east of Cape Road Bentley
suffk
councilor buby you're not sitting as a
ward member you're staying as a member
of the committee aren't you as the ward
member that's correct chair thank
you right can I now invite the case
officer Emily to present the scheme to
the committee thank you
Emily uh good morning
members this application DC stroke 23
stoke 03
652 at the site addressed as land east
of Cable Road Bentley is an outline
proposal for 24 dwellings which includes
eight affordable units and public open
space access is to be considered but the
matters of landscaping layout scale and
appearance are
reserved this present
is provided as a further Visual and
spoken accompaniment to committee report
and is not Des designed to supplant the
information contained in that report it
is intended to provide members with an
introduction to the application and as a
springboard for discussion of the
information in the report of points
raised by speakers and in other
representations since the publication of
the committee report Please be aware the
public reconsultation closed yesterday
on the 28th of November in respect of
the additional information provided by
the agent and the revised indicative
proposed site layout plan which
had The Pedestrian connection to the
public footpath 55 adjacent to the site
removed those who responded had made
representation before and did not change
stance so today a total of 14 public
representations have been received with
12 objections One support and one
neutral comment made reconsultation
responses have also been received from
the council's aror cultural officer
raising no objection to the proposal
subject to their conditions to safeguard
the um the trees to be retained on
site an additional objection from
Bentley Parish Council has also been
received D um in regard to the housing
needs assessment supporting this
application they have supplied us with a
list of unbuilt and extent planning
permissions for new housing within
Bentley that would um is proposed to
meet the 52 houses identified to be
needed for the area these comments have
been tabled as papers for your
consideration
as this Arrow image shows the site is in
the pink hatched area it is outside the
settlement boundary the line in brown is
the um boundary drawn by the previous
local plan of 2006 which has been
brought forward into the joint local
plan under the policy sp03 for spatial
strategy policy sp03 does not not
support new development in the
countryside which the site would be
um there are only a few limited
circumstances under
sp03 where such development would be
allowable um those would be if the site
is allocated already or is in accordance
with a made neighborhood plan um the
development Accords with paragraph 80 of
the
mppf or um the development Accords with
another policy within the joint local
plan that would allow that development
to take place in the
countryside the green Dash lines you can
see there are the public footpath
network running through the
countryside the green line adjacent to
the site boundary there is public um
public footpath 55 that I previously
mentioned which is now taken out of the
proposed indicative site layout for the
scheme
uh the site area is approximately 1.19
hectares um it's important to note that
previously this site was put forward as
part of a larger parcel of land labeled
in the blue hatch there as ss1
138 that was put forward under the
Strategic housing economic availability
assessment during 2020 prior to the
local plan joint local plan coming
forward um however that site was
discounted due to poor connectivity to
the existing
settlement um so again under policy sp03
is important to note that this um
proposal
potentially would need to demonstrate
accordance with the neighborhood
plan or be an allocated site
which it was not successful in this
application under
Sheila for this application a proposed
connectivity plan has been submitted to
support and it highlights the um
relatively few services available within
the village of Bentley um Bentley under
the previous local plan was designated
as a hint land Village the services that
have been marked up here are in the
yellow and pink dots the nearest to the
site are the community owned Pub and
Shop the Red Dot
is yes
sorry here we go this is the community
Pub and Shop here the
um the Red Dot here is the Village Hall
the Green Dot is the um hair salon
within Bentley um you can also see the
hatched areas here also close to the
site are the already existing um public
open space so the playing fields and the
recreational land up here more distant
in Orange is a um primary
school and again the blue this is the
connection through from the public
footpath 55 previously
mentioned um from the existing site plan
and photographs you can see that the
land is laid out in three parts so um it
was formerly used as a fruit farm and is
presented as vacant land in the
application the area closest to the
Capal Road here has several rows of
steak set out for growing of vines those
are still in place and can be seen on
this Photograph here of the site towards
the rear closest to the public footpath
the land is semi naturalized grassland
um and that can be seen here from this
Photograph um quite well and to the
South here there are a couple of poly
tunnels present and some small out
buildings A Little Pond behind those and
an area of hard standing for parking
which forms the existing
access there's hedge row along here to
the um front of the site HED R around
most of the boundaries actually and
several trees lining the foot paath here
as well shown on this plan um this top
photograph here was taken looking from
the public foot path into the site and
this bottom photograph here was taken
from the access point looking into the
site so you can get a sense of um how it
relates to one another
there an indicative proposed site layout
plan has been provided for this
application and shows um the housing
tenure and mix although the layout and
scale are matchs reserved the housing
ranges from four beds towards the front
here um to two bedroom
Bungalows um and one and two bedroom
Flats the ases mark the mark the eight
affordables that are proposed and this
site layout suggests that they would be
located towards the footpath in a
cluster here so there's a row of Terrace
twostory houses the Two Flats and
another Terrace house um and another
couple of semi- detached houses um
ranging from three bedrooms down to
obviously the one bedroom Flats there in
the affordable
range this is the most Recon um revised
copy of the proposed site layout and
it's important to note that the previous
connection to that public footpath 55
has now been removed from the scheme as
presented um the access is shown to be
relocated here and the introduction of a
um new public footpath ad joining to the
village is shown on this site
plan uh it should be noted that joint
local plan policy sp03 as said before
makes some allowance for new development
in the countryside where it is in
accordance with a neighborhood plan
Bentley does have a neighborhood plan
that was adopted during December
um this includes policy Ben one um which
allows for a um raw exception site to be
um come forward for affordable housing
or a community Le housing scheme and
that would allow for um development in
the countryside if those um expectations
were met from the policy um it's
important to note that this is a market
legged housing scheme as proposed
whereas this policy is U requiring um
the market element to be subsidiary to
the affordable element um so so far the
scheme does not demonstrate accordance
with policy
benan and therefore would not Accord
with policy s03
IA jump back
um this policy map here from the
neighborhood plan also shows some
features of local Contra um for context
the purple Dots here show buildings of
local significance you'll note there's
three quite close to the site area and
again the green lines which are dashed
this time show um what is considered the
vegetated boundary of the village and
then the large P largest public open
space adjacent to the site here should
be
[Applause]
noted
uh these next few slides um are to show
you the local context of the site they
um show these buildings of local
significance so this is link house that
dates from 16th century and can be seen
on approach to the Village from the
capable Road and the map in the corner
shows the angle that the photograph was
taken and again the purple dot in the
context of the site location
so that was the first building you see
when you entering the Village from C
Road um this building is the
community-owned pub also building of
local significance the case is altered
it also hosts the community stores and
um this photo again shows with the map
the location of the
building the last of the closest local
buildings of significance to the site is
the witch step Cottage this dates from
the 17th century um it's notable for the
unusual feature of its chimney stack
here um but more importantly this is the
first building that you see when you
approach The Village from that um public
footpath 55 running um adjacent to the
site
here and that's before you reach um down
case Lane the cases I altered um
H this slide shows the proposed tree
retention plan that has been put forward
for the application although um it
should be noted that Landscaping is a
reserved matter it would suggest that
the intention is to retain um the
vegetated uh settlement boundary under
the neighborhood local development plan
um to remove a portion of the hedge row
at the northern boundary but retain most
of it in place um and again some hedro
boundaries are retained on this kind of
angled dog leg boundary here and the
boundary to the South with a settlement
however the hedge row along Cable Road
would be required to be removed um for
the formation of the new access that
would be relocated from here where it is
presently to a more centralized
position uh this is what it would look
like in context so this is the hedge row
that is proposed to be removed from the
site boundary with Capal Road and at the
rear here you can see the vegetated um
set settlement boundary on to the
neighborhood plan um along the public
footpath 55 and just the poly tunnel so
this little tree here would be removed
and so with this large tree here as well
um this slide also shows quite well the
narrow P um foot path which is running
along Cal Road
um and again the intention would be to
take away this hedge row and install a
um footpath of Greater width to connect
the site with the
settlement
as proposed and the indicative um site
layout it's also um important to note
that although this can be seen now um
the development would uh obviously
occupy the space and the vegetated um
buil builtup Edge would um potentially
be eroded from vision from the cable
Road
uh this is the indicative proposed site
layout plan for the public open space
for the
scheme um
0.12 hectar for the 1.19 hectar site
have been put forward um in two areas
shown here the more Central area and the
linear Park adjacent to the fo PA here
um the public realm team have indicated
through consultation that this provision
is under size but would be um accepted
by them with some reservation about how
usable this space would
be from comparison with the neighborhood
um
plan the proposed site layout against
the um example put forward in the
Bentley design guide can be seen here
um it's evident from the quantity that
of 24 dwellings proposed that um the
scheme would represent overd development
of the plot and it has
been
um
not shown due regard to the design
guidance put forward in the neighborhood
plan it's also noteworthy that the
highways team have raised concern um
during their consultation about the
ability for vehicles to enter the
Bentley Playing Fields adjacent and um
separated by that public footpath 55
um through the linear Park and they have
requested um information about a means
of prevention of those Vehicles entering
the site through
there the agent has indicated that that
could be um addressed under a reserve
matters
application um but a holding objection
is in place from the highways team for
that concern and some other matters of
clarification at the moment this photo
was taken from the Cal Road looking into
to the site when it was taken there was
a vehicle already present within there
um but I'm not sure how that came to
be the countryside footpath route here
is shown by this photograph for um
footpath 55 and you can see the witch
step Cottage again is the first building
that you encounter upon approach into
the settlement on this side is the site
boundary and here is the other access
through to the um Bentley plan Fields
public open space um the
public oh sorry the suffet constabulary
have also commented with raising concern
that the linear public space adjacent to
the footpath which is already
overshadowed May um worsen that impact
and lead to an area with little
surveillance in the presently indicative
site layout as it's
presented the applicants have also put
forward indicative design precedence for
the appearance of the development these
are shown as a the brick is a um
scheme in great Bentley Essex whereas
the rendered housing here is from deam
in
saur um again it's important to note
that this suggests that the development
could take a more traditional vacular
looking appearance um although that
matter is
reserved uh from the are image again you
can see that the site is slightly
detached from the settlement boundary
here by this small wedge um and is
noticeable that in recent years linear
development has um changed um to the
north of the site along Capal Road
outside of the settlement
boundary um which has resulted in
character variation between the
countryside housing and that of the
settlement which is much denser
um and especially more um prominent
towards the Eastern end of the village
there the site acts as an important
breaking point between the encroaching
linear development from the Cal Road and
the um historic buildings we saw there
and the more kind of um lower density
end of the Bentley settlement
for further context um these are photos
taken from the Capal Road um showing the
surrounding development and how that has
changed in recent times the top photo
shows um the property called Nursery
Cottages which was within that wedge
area I showed separating the um site
from the settlement
boundary uh that has been built
relatively recently um through
subdivided Garden land its appearance is
harmonious with the um first buildings
you encounter um upon entry to the
settlement there just in the distance so
it takes a much more vernacular
appearance whereas the bottom photo
shows um the immediate adjac neighbor
for funa and
Wayside um Fortuna was also built um in
recent times outside of the settlement
boundary through subdivided Garden land
but these properties take on a much more
contemporary um appearance and they are
obviously of a much larger
scale typically these are also set back
at a greater distance from the road as
you move along the Cal Road here
uh this photo shows the streetcape from
the public footpath west of kol road on
the opposite side of the site
essentially so this blue arrow here
shows roughly where I took that from um
again you can see the far left house
here Rowan Acres was um has been built
as a replacement dwelling of much larger
scale um in a a georan type um athetic
the next door property pemy house was
also newb built um property in recent
times through subdivided Garden land um
that's again a very large
property all set back at similar
distances um the red marker here shows
the approximate location of the site as
a Breaking Point and there should don't
sure you can see it very well but there
was um you can just see the roof line of
the other property Nursery Cottages in
the far distance here and the settlement
is almost indistinguishable at a
distance on
approach this is the view from the road
in the opposite direction towards where
the site is so here you could just about
see um Fortuna in the distance and again
this is Nursery Cottages the new built
property that mimics the pattern of
development from the
settlement
um the site is about here and the 24
dwellings could potentially disturb this
gentle um and gradual transition to to
the settlement seen with the older
buildings moving further towards those
which we saw earlier which are the ones
of local
significance in fact I think the first
one we looked at linkous it starts here
and here is the um turning head for
burle road as well
another um one we'll look at in a
minute um burgal Road here along that
turning head
um is is mainly just Bungalows of 20th
century building these are particularly
low Ling so from a far um approaching
the stim the buil top area is um
indistinguishable although these are
quite regimented and densely packed
in um so finally the application is
recommended for
refusal um based on the grounds that the
principal of development would be
contrary to
sp03 and Ben one it does not represent a
affordable housing scheme in a roar
exception site or a community Le scheme
under their neighborhood plan and it is
um new development within the
countryside that does not Accord with
another policy in the joint local plan
and is not an allocated site already um
the landscape impact through the loss of
the hedro for the formation of the new
access is considered to be harmful um
both under policies LP
1777 um and LP 24 of the joint local
plan and um also it's not in accordance
with the direction of the policies of
their neighborhood plan um the
development does not uh demonstrate due
regard to its sound surroundings um it
would um this amount of development
would potentially lead to
overdevelopment of the site and have
harmful consequences for the character
of the Village um the occupants will
rely heavily upon private vehicle usage
it has previously been
um assessed that the connection to the
um village through the Sheila scheme
um is um poor and that site was
dismissed for that reason although part
of a larger proportion of land um and
also we have a lack of um s106
provision for um secured for Education
libraries and Waste Services that would
be necessary to serve the
development no sorry I've got that wrong
sorry for school bus um monitoring of
that and highways Works to connect the
um the site up with the with the village
the um lack of still contribution was
actually for the education libraries and
Waste
Services um and that's that's the end of
my
presentation thank you
Emily any questions to the officer
Council Busby just that last point I
didn't understand why there's a lack of
sill
contribution that should say lack of
rams actually rather than
sill you're correct you shouldn't say
that better Define r
you better Define RAM for the
benefit recreational area mitigation
scheme sorry um so development which has
uh housing within the zone of influence
of the store and oil esteres U makes a
contribution to um um you know looking
after those areas um so it's a simple
thing to do and the applicant would do
it if they were going to be approved
it's it's a simple legal agreement which
is done in two days but we do have to if
we refusing we do have to cite it as a
reason for refusal otherwise the
appellant may say well you didn't refuse
it for that reason so therefore I'm not
paying it so it's that and it's it's a
lack of
106 thank you
Mark does that answer your
question
okay can
grandon thank you chair um can I ask um
we might need slide eight or
19 um on The Villages neighborhood plan
could you tell me where they they would
like to put um any future development
please could you show me where that
would be cited if they um opted have if
if if they could choose to put um new
development where in the
village have they indicated that would
be
please uh that may be best asked to the
parish um later on but before um under
the Sheila um assessment it was land
here and here that had been um put
forward as a candidate and was um
considered appropriate to host
development I can get the other slide at
the start up
to show you that
again so this site here and
here thank
you I can probably I was just going to
answer the question for C I was just
going to help Catherine with the answer
to that question if you
like they haven't put any allocated
sites in the neighborhood plan because
they've already achieved the number of
houses that they were requested to do in
fact they more than achieved it however
they will be looking forward to
community sites or uh rural exception
sites and this could be one of
those councelor
Parker uh yeah thank you chair I just
want to expand on that last point about
the uh the s/ Rams um contribution
surely uh well I just need some
understanding would that not be a matter
for reserved matters or would that be I
mean this is outlin isn't it so it's not
something we consider now anyway is it
no you do it up front basically if you
can do anything up front you do it up
front so we know um we would know the
number of dwellings so we'd know what
the Rams contribution would be we'd also
know what the 106 contributions would be
so we do it we would do it to
outline
councelor beer um thank you Mr chairman
could I have slide 24
please
thank you um well you've obviously got
enough reasons there for refusal but
could you please comment on um o
occupants will be heavily Reliant upon
the private most private vehicle usage
well surely Mr chairman this applies in
most of our Villages so why is this
being used here it looks a bit
heavy-handed to me but perhaps the the
officer could answer or somebody
um it it stems from the
UN it stems from the unsustainable
location of the development so it's
inherently unsustainable within the
countryside um it's car dominated as
well and there's
um a lack of or there's relatively few
services within the village of bentle so
there's an expectation that to meet
their day-to-day needs they would need
to travel quite often
um far distances to the larger
settlements such as CLE St
Mary thank you I'll get the area
planning
manager I'll get the area planning
manager to just expand on that if you
would in
mind thank you chair I I hear what
you're saying um um councelor be because
obviously in a largely rural District
you're right um a lot of the
developments will be car dependent so w
we put it in there I think we have to
start from the principle of um a
sustainable location for housing so
that's where spbo1 starts off and then
also SBO 3 touches on it as well um
there are as K off said few facilities
there so the likelihood is that the
occupants would be needing to use cars
um and we're starting from the point
where we just put housing in settlement
B countries as per
spo3 um and we don't put them in places
where we don't think they should go
because we think people have to use the
car the whole time um if you spin
forward a few years and we've you know
we need another fiveyear housing land
Supply we might be looking at places
which at the moment we think are
undesirable but we see this as
undesirable in Principle as per spo3 and
Ben one but also because it's it's
relatively unsustainable and would
require car
use
is it about the same subject or pardon
yes okay I'm sorry Mark that's that's
ridiculous I mean this it's a site that
is outside the village boundary just
because it's a line it's right next door
to houses either side of it and opposite
it they're in the same location they're
reliant on a car just the same I in this
instance it is just not an argument one
way or the other I'm afraid so I agree
with
pet that that's for you as a side
members if you think that that line
should be struck out I I think we it's
probably useful to leave a
sustainability argument in there if we
have to fight an appeal but that's
that's your decisions can I ask another
question relating to that Mr chairman
yeah goad do we need to have that
particular line in those reasons for
refusal because that's the point I've
never seen it in many others and I
understand except sustainability but
that isn't really how that reads and uh
I I'm just uh well I have to agree I
don't accept what you but but you and
your officers are saying at all thank
you let's look at what the report says
and what the bullet points are there and
just see whether that is is better for
you turn to that actually got
okay I think what you got to realize to
a certain extent is that we're now in a
different period we now have a joint
local plan and we certainly had a
neighborhood plan for Bentley so perhaps
things are a little bit different from
what they were perhaps the last time you
sat on this committee Council Busby
anyway moving on councilor gred thank
you chair um on page 32 of our
report um it says that one of the um
reasons for the refusal is the number of
units sought would overdevelop the
site um but so is there a reason why
that that is not listed as one of the
reasons for um refusal on the list or
did I
misunderstand something in the um I
think it's a slight mismatch between
slide 24 and what you've got in your
report actually officers sorry members
um if you look at the bullet pointed
reasons refusal at the bottom of the
report I think there are 1 two 3 four
five six seven of them
um there is something there which um yes
point the fourth bullet point does cover
that yes so so so sorry what I what I'm
saying is um on page 32 I have got the
right yeah so on page 32 it says one of
the reasons for refusal was over
development of the site but that wasn't
listed for uh on the um reasons for
refusal on the side is there a reason
that that hasn't been included
please could we have the slides back up
please um it was covered more in a
character sense from the development
does not demonstate regard to its
surroundings so a holistic design sense
is what that was for that short bullet
point just just to clarify I would turn
to the report what it says in the report
those are the proposed reasons for
refusal oh are they those seven bullet
points yeah that that was a a sort of Av
verion of but it there it Strays a
little bit from those exact bullet
points that that is the recommendation
so when you're voting look at the report
and we can we can I can I can read them
out if you want at the time of voting
but those refusal yes because yes thank
you that that would be help helpful and
um because that to me seems one of the
um obvious points but it I was surprised
not to sit it on there and thought there
must be a reason for it thank
you hello yes um on slide 12 um there
was a hedro along the northern boundary
that I think you said was going to be
removed was that right or did I
misunderstand understand
that was it for Access along I was just
yeah wondering I know the the boundary
along the road was going to be removed
for the for the the road into the
housing but the very
Northern there we are yeah the northern
bit at the top so is there is that
access I I I didn't quite understand why
it would be reduced slightly oh it would
be reduced not removed okay so there's
there's still a little a little bit of
green there which is um existing Hedges
to be retained yeah the arbor culture
officer within the table papers does
comment I believe on this it was either
them or the Play services team that it
would be a good thing to do to um cut
back the hedge row it's in a poor state
of condition so um it would be a good
opportunity to
um give it some attention that it needs
I'm I'm not the on that I'm afraid yeah
that's fine um can I ask another quick
can I
just can you clarify it for us
quickly it's to be retained and enhanced
so the only removal was to the front of
the site um and again we're looking to
step it back rejuvenate but equally
provide that access to the site so thank
you for clarification you wanted another
question yes I'm I'm not sure if this is
the right time to ask but um I looked at
the ecological report for this site and
it says that there's no Pond and yet on
the introduction here it says there is a
pond so it seems that
the the people who did the ecological
report obviously missed the pond it
seems to be around the buildings behind
there's a shed and some poly tunnels so
um the fact that you know there could be
amphibians living in that pond and it's
obviously been missed
well quickly asked the agent is there a
pond or not find that point um
previously it was um a nursery and it
was a hold holding tank so it was a it
was a TP filled of water so they used it
just to top up their water system so
that has been
removed yes so it wasn't a proper Pond
thank you thank you very much you happy
with
that any more questions for the
officer if not thank you very much for
your first one the
committee pretty we couldn't keep the
rck milers
[Music]
on thanks moving
on um we have a public speaker I
understand from uh Bentley Parish
Council and she's coming to us remotely
is that
correct and it's Marian
Munday
hello can you hear
me I can I you're a bit loud but but
never mind um that's better I'll turn
myself down it's better I've been too
quiet I'm just is that that's fine I'm
just going to remind the committee that
um if you wish when to ask question of
this speaker you will have to absolutely
ensure that you've got your microphone
open I'm most probably the biggest fell
in doing that but missing out but that's
where I've warned you thank you Marian
you have three minutes to address the
committee thank you um Bentley is a
small Hinterland Village um which has
grown considerably in The Last 5 Years
31 outstanding planning permissions at
the 1 of April 2018 have now been built
or building started in addition another
18 planning permissions have been
approved since April 201 18 where most
are in the process of being built
totaling 49 houses this equates to
approximately 15% growth rate over five
years if this application is granted
this would increase to a 21% growth rate
it is the case that in the submitted
version of bab's joint local plan
spatial distribution identified that
only 9% of all housing in babber should
be accommodated in hinan
villages as described by the planning
officer in her very useful report this
planning application is inappropriate in
size scale layout and character and
being outside the settlement boundary is
contrary to Bentley's neighborhood plan
and bab's adopted joint local plan part
one um policy 0 sp03 of baby's joint
local plan only allows development
outside of the settlement boundary in
exceptional
circumstances and this development is
not in accord with any of those other
relevant policies or our policy Bend one
of our neighborhood plan where
development outside of the settlement
boundary is only supported for the
development of small scale affordable
housing schemes on Rural exception sites
where there is a proven local
need although adjacent to the settlement
boundary and so accessible to the small
community shop Hub and playing field
most of the services required by
families would need to be accessed
Beyond The Village particularly in cable
St Mary there is no direct public
transport linked to cable from Bentley
so there would be a heavy Reliance on
the motorc car and just to add to that
it is almost impossible to walk or cycle
to Cable either um very dangerous to do
so um so there's no sustainable method
of getting into our core village where
our doctors dentists libraries Co-op Etc
are um there is only one daily bus
service into whip switch that only
operates in term time and this is is not
a Time suitable for commuters and the
other major Point that's been missed um
our main route through the village is a
connection point between the a137 and
the a12 and is frequently used by
Vehicles as a cut through between those
two roads when there's problem at the
cop dock interchange and this is our
problem is that we already have a large
number of vehicles coming through our
village that aren't associated with our
village at all and to add that burden um
which would be um not environmentally
friendly apart from anything else in the
report on the examination of Baba's
joint local plan the inspector comments
on the revised policy sp03 and I quote
if housing development were to be
permitted adjoining settlement
boundaries this would result in the
significant and unsustainable expansion
of many small relatively isolated
settlements with minimal facilities
Maran thank you very much but your time
is
up I will quickly see if anybody wants
to
ask Maran a question Council
register uh thank you for your report
Marian um you your point so to clarify
can you clarify if there you say that
there's very limited public transport I
bus services serving
Bentley and the part s out of the routs
out of uh Bentley aren't particularly
safe for cycling so they're only really
s useful for very confident and safe
cyclists is that correct yes yes I mean
to say the main road through Bentley um
is used by um very large lorries to
access um the tatting stone um uh skip
um uh and Quarry um so they often use us
as a cut through so you've got 20 ton
lorries going through the Village um and
there is no foot path connecting beyond
that small um foot path that you saw on
some of the photographs um and in actual
fact that isn't even a foot path that is
um a ditch that was covered in and
tacked over so it's very very narrow but
there's if you wanted to walk to Cle it
would be for a very fit person at least
at least a 45 minute walk through very
muddly muddy bridleways um and Fields
and there is just not any sustainable
travel route to get to our uh core
Village of
CLE uh regarding the buses um there is
one bus service that leaves Bentley at
9:35 um goes into ipswitch um and
doesn't return until 10 3 in the
afternoon so clearly it's of little use
to commuters um we have people working
in London commuting into London who need
to drive to to manry station for
instance there's no way of getting to
any um you know sustainable travel um
hub from Bentley um without getting in a
car thank you very much thank you any
more
questions no and thank you
Maran thank
you Mr Ben Moore Who's acting as the
agent I believe you have three minutes
to address the
committee on the screen for this just
for the purpose of the members if
possible a reason why not let's see if
we can find it thank you very much
okay your time starts now perfect UMD
like to thank all the members here today
for attending and um the counselors um
as you're all aware the developments for
24 units which is inclusive of four um
eight affordable homes which have been
identified in the hous of needs
assessment undertaken and by Pioneer the
applicant has extensive experience in
providing affordable homes through both
development and direct to the Housing
Association so is's familiar with the
requirements and needs and it would be
in their best intent to deliver the
scheme in ordering to provide the
housing
need the site plan aims to provide
continuity in the frontage to the
Southwest fronting the highway infilling
the larger houses to the north and
providing pedestrian links to the main
village larger dwellings are cited to
the highway Frontier to sit well against
the large existing properties along the
highway which Echo the linear
development behind this is a green
public open space that forms the center
of the site the north of the site is
designed to allow the shared surface to
provide a quiet and overlooked public
realm a mix of house types are proposed
to aim to give a mix that would be
positive contribution to the housing
available in the
village this will also offer improved
connectivity to the existing Village if
we could just refer to slide for on the
screen um you know whilst we appreciate
um the propal is contrary to spo3 and
bo1 it does afford offer a affordable
housing to the village and what you need
to consider is there's not many
companies which will come forward to
offer this and it needs to be balanced
by market housing although the site is
outside of the settlement boundary it
abuts one side of the proposed
development and it isn't detriment of in
its proposed location there are no
technical reasons to refuse this
development the public benefits of
development out outweigh the harm there
are no allocations and no homes
currently coming through which offer
this number Affordable units in Bentley
our applicant will of course be pleased
to offer any Rams and seal contributions
and similarly provide 106 allocations on
approval of this scheme and it's finally
noted the connectivity and use of
vehicles the development is on the
outside of the village and has great
connectivity to the a12 thank you there
much
thank you very much are there any
questions for the agent councelor beer
um just to clarify uh you said eight
hous and needs you did the survey or um
Pioneer so we had a a specialist housing
needs assessor undertake a report for us
and they've allocate um identified eight
eight houses required in gr pen in and
so they are needed at this particular
time that is what the housing needs as
identified yes thank
you councelor
car thank you um and just to re clarify
on that point what is the breakup of the
affordable homes are they um it's as
demonstrated in the site plan um you
just bear with me a second so the
affordable housing which we're proposing
a three beds two number two beds two
number two Bungalows two number and two
one-bedroom Flats sorry that was that
was my bad um I'm more meant is it is it
um affordable is it shared ownership is
um there's a mix so there is a a mix of
allocations in there unfortunately I
don't have the it a hand but there
there's um there's I think there's one
of each category so as a minimum thank
you thank you PR
gra there's no way of guaranteeing that
these will go to local people I don't
think is there with affordable housing
schemes unfortunately that's that's not
for me to answer that question um but
certainly there's there's a need
identified so I'd expect that there
would be either downsizing or for
families thank you thank
you sorry to clarify no no there isn't
um it's based on A districtwide needs
assessment so so it could come from
anybody in the district um you could
only really tie that down if it was
something called a rural exception
scheme which also gives perpetuity of
affordable ownership rather than
something that could be right to buy a
few years down the
line could it be um there's a system of
stair casing isn't there where it could
be possibly brought in but there's no
guarantee uh and could it be made a
condition
um there is staircasing option but it's
it's not necessarily always used on on
these schemes um and it couldn't be
conditioned that we'd have to be Power
106 councelor beer you wanted
to yes Mr chairman um I was under the
impression that councelor Ma managed to
get some uh affordable housing uh
earmarked for local residents now I
could be totally wrong here but I have
heard somewhere we have we did agree to
some being uh approved and they the
local people did have a choice of some
of them perhaps not all of them but we
have done that in the past so I would
like us to really find out the answer to
that because uh it's pretty she's not
here but I'm sure she did okay okay
thank you Council be CC you you clarify
that uh chair yes I think I can answer
that it was Chon place which is where I
actually live and some there was a
staircasing that went on there and some
yeah it was four or five I think and
some did but I have actually spoken to
the residents and some were from inside
the area and some weren't so the reality
doesn't always match up with the desire
okay can happen can happen yes thank you
any more questions for the
agent councel beer uh if if that was the
case and we asked for um them to award
uh housing needs to local people first
um could we put a uh uh could we have X
amount guaranteed three or four um I
don't know if that's possible I'd love
to say we'd be pleased to but ultimately
it would come down to the 106 agreement
yeah we can't um the the quoted the
often quoted chilon case I've spoken to
the housing strategic housing office
about this it was a little bit regular
what happened there I think after
committee they oh sorry um it it was um
the Chilton case was unusual um it's I
don't know how it happened but it did um
and I think four or five houses were
secured and I think having spoken I
don't believe any of them were taken up
by locals I could be wrong um the way
that was done was a little unusual and I
wouldn't wouldn't use that as a
precedent for any future
cases okay well hang on hang
on question to the agent are you are you
saying it's not within your power to do
this unfortunately not okay does that
answer well yes that part does but
following on from what the two plan
offers said if we've done it somewhere
and it was reasonably successful wait a
momenta because uh my colleague here who
lives there says that he spoken to some
and they did come from inside the
district I don't think we should just
decide that we can't investigate this
because it's not acceptable um uh two
plan officer to say well that was
something that was done and we don't
quite know how and we're not sure that
was such a good idea it was a good idea
because some local people did get houses
so I I'm inclined to think that we need
more information on this Council beer
I'm going to stop you there I'm going to
say are there any more questions for the
agent because that's not a question for
the
agent if not thank you very much let you
sit
down councilor beer if you want to raise
that matter raise it during debate I
think thank you I will do but I was
responding to the chief plan and
officer's
comments
okay you've got your hand up councelor
gron may I please ask a question to the
officers or is that later on that I can
do that yes ask
thank you um so in the reasons for
refusal um it mentions over development
could you please explain how this um
application um comes under the
description of overdevelopment
please
I think um the overdevelopment was tried
to be captured within development does
not
demonstrate yes the
overdevelopment um reason refusal has
been tried to be rephrased within the
development does not demonstrate regard
to the surroundings so if you go back
to
yeah okay so um this is the indicative
proposed site plan with the 24 dwellings
um laid out within it Place Services
Landscaping have commented saying that
this is a compacted site um layout and
they have um indicated that this is um
quite a dense um scheme that does not um
correlate with the surrounding
development particularly well so as we
um had from the photos of the context
it's quite gradual um and the clustering
within the settlement there are areas
that are much more um regimented of the
branching roads but these tend to be
towards the east so it's the
overdevelopment is not is more of a um
concern in the sense that it disturbs
the pattern of development and the the
car it's harmful to the character of the
area so it would take away the open
space buffer between the linear um
properties that have been redeveloped in
recent times within the countryside
housing um and the gradual and gentle
transition to those more traditional
properties we saw within the photos
which are the local buildings of
significance so the in there's impacts
from developing the site to the 24
dwellings um to the to the character of
the settlement essentially is is the
reason for refusal I hope that explains
a little bit
better okay
I will now open up the item for
debate as the ward member I will invite
councelor Busby to start off you don't
have to you're not obliged to but but
the offer is
there you'll come back in
later I can't hear you haven't turned
your microphone okay um just very
briefly just to answer Katherine's
question really it's a distinct part of
the village
to the to the west of of this site you
saw those big houses that's the entrance
into the village and that's a distinct
entrance you get from there this
provides a break between those houses
and the old you saw the witch Cottage
and Link house and the old center of the
village the pub Etc this is a natural
break this site if you put this 24
houses in there then that eradicates
that break let's face it 24 houses in
one .19 hectares is not over development
normally but if you go further on then
into the village to the east then the
development is much denser and therefore
it would be appropriate further on if
you like so it's it's just a particular
site which is yeah that's right it's the
context that makes it important here
um and it is a site that it's it perhaps
if you look at the Village as a whole it
is the best site in the village for any
future development but the village are
very keen on getting it that site right
because it is important it is the best
one therefore they want the right thing
in it Community Land Trust is perhaps
the way they would like to go they've
got plans to put uh allotments Etc on
that side the the Green Space the open
space that's presented on this
development is useless it's not really
recreational space it's not Green Space
you can't do anything with it and they
would like to make the better use of
that particular um site in terms of
housing very specific need and of course
then if it is a Community Land Trust
then you can make the housing for the
locals otherwise everybody has to take
their chance on the housing L um and
really it's it's quite
straightforward doesn't matter how
really how good this I think the the
application is it's it is outside of the
village
boundary it's uh not in the in the
neighborhood
plan hands a tide I think you have to
say refusal and I think that's where the
officers have come
from thank you who next councelor
Parker yeah thank you chair so um to
what extent can we pick um Council
Busby's um Brian can I ask Council buby
a question um Can the chair is that all
right so um because fascinating uh
listening to my colleague on on the left
here as well about affordability and
listening to yourself about Community
Land Trust and and and all the rest of
it but actually how relevant is is any
of this because um I I know ownership uh
isn't isn't a particular issue but but
who actually owns this land I mean if if
if they want to put a Community Land
Trust together can they do that anyway
if they don't own this land um and
similarly I suppose to to Council of be
I
suppose uh it's loadable and we
absolutely should be looking to provide
affordable housing above uh above all
else in my opinion um but actually it's
largely irrelevant on this application
is it not because this is an outline
application and we can't give any
guarantees as to what might come forward
anyway so there's two points there but I
wonder if if councelor Busby could
answer the first point
please uh
um I probably could but I probably
shouldn't um I probably know too much
about who owns it and what the deals are
Etc
to um potential deals are the pr so I
can't really mention
that thank you C advis first time I've
seen you stuck for an
answer Council register
um yes so we've we've heard about the
concerns that the car dependency the
dependency upon the car for
transportation is grounds for refusal
but consider this there is no
clearly we've heard that there is no
effective public
transport secondly a third of the people
in this development will be in
affordable housing and people in
affordable housing are far more like ly
to be uh unable to drive or have access
to a vehicle um we're going to end up I
think you could end up uh
creating more road trips car trips and
our big problem in suffk is we have too
many car trips it's not we've got too
many cars we've got too many car trips
we need to start thinking forward and
working and making sure that
developments happen where there is good
public transport where there
eventually have got safe coherent cycle
cycle route so people have an
alternative to using the car this
clearly has n none of that and um I
think unlikely to have it by the time it
would be built if it was
approved thank
you any more Council
gring thank you could I ask a question
of the local member
please bearing in mind his last track
record you may not get an answer but
please car
on um so it seems to me that Bentley has
quite a a strong local community because
they bought their local PB and shop and
so
on
so are there other and you were
mentioning the vague possibility of a
Community Land Trust
situation is there an
appetite
for um this kind of thing in the village
is there still a strong
Community feeling and so
on yes it's a great Village there has
got a uh a good lot of volunteers they
run the pub they run the the shop um
they've put forward a very good NA plan
they run all kinds of
events a community land trust is a
different game altogether it's um going
to take a lot of effort uh perhaps even
more than a neighborhood plant putting a
neighborhood plant together and over a
longer period of time so
um I don't believe they have anybody
that's come forward yet to do that that
doesn't mean that there won't be if
they're asked especially if um The
Village understand the benefits but it's
it's a big commitment let's put it that
way thank you thank
you Council
Rob the point the point being with all
of these communities they still all need
their cars because if we I mean we can
if we're not careful we talk we start
talking about affordable housing only in
towns because
people can only access the immunities in
towns so I think that um you know we
have to be careful there but I think you
know community-led housing project could
be a way to go but again by its very
nature it would be people with less
means to travel um uh by private
Vehicles anyone else want councelor beer
go on well just on those last points um
in in our Villages um we've always had
this problem uh over the years and I
think it's not helpful to blame the
motorers and the motor car all the time
um cyclers and
pedestrians uh yes have a right to use
the road and I'd be the first to
Advocate that um but to suggest or to
imply that uh affordable
homes in The Villages can only go to
people who've got motor cars or haven't
got Motor Cars isn't right either um and
I would have said that if we could have
get people in the villages to use the
local facilities if they're available
that is a good way forward but I think
in a real world you have to understand
that there is in the bus routes in the
village at the moment there isn't uh all
the foot paths and cycle ways that we'd
like and if if you for think that this
sort of thing helps bring that forward
quickly you're greatly mistaken because
it doesn't it it's got to be worked out
with infrastructure and developments in
these villages to help provide some of
these so I I I do think it's um not
right to constantly knock the motors and
the motor car thank
thank you councilor beer are there any
more
comments anybody else in that case
councelor
Parker um well actually chair I was just
going to move things along actually in
the in the absence of any other comments
I'm going to make a proposal if if I can
that we um uh we agree with the
officer's recommendation actually to uh
to refuse this application for all the
um reasons that are given in the report
um and if I could just add to that as
well for me what I think is really
Paramount actually in in all of this uh
is the Bentley neighborhood plan
actually um and and I think that
volunteers put thousands of of hours
together volunteer hours and and to um
to do anything other uh than to go with
a recommendation I think would would be
a travesty to um to the community that
that we ask to help guide us in this
committee so um I propose we refuse the
application chair thank you councilor
Parker do I have a second uh oh too many
hands going up uh I I'll take councel
register thank you uh yeah I I second
that proposal and uh yeah having worked
on a neighborhood plan in mford it's
like if you ignore it you're basically
saying that what a waste of time and
money and I think this is needs
refusal thank
you any more comments
councelor beer uh well thank you Mr
chairman I just wanted to say that uh
whilst I agree wholeheartedly with my
colleague here uh on um the um proposal
he's putting forward with one exception
there is one item line in there that I
cannot agree to and in that case I will
not be voting for the application
application for refusal thank you what
was what was that the the the the line
regarding the uh well the you'd want the
exact Worden that's on the um uh slide
24 I think it's the fifth bullet point
which I mentioned right at the
beginning okay thank you sorry so uh I
think it says the occupants would have
heavy Reliance upon private Motor
Vehicles for use for their transport
needs well this happens in the
countryside Villages all the time thank
you I don't accept that thank you
councilor any other comments if not I'll
get the
um area planning manager to read out
exactly what you're voting for well
chair what Sor in a way I agree with
councel be but it's there's nothing
wrong with that
statement because the occupants of that
site as in the whole of Bentley will are
heavily reliant on a car it's not an
incorrect statement it's just irrelevant
really
please if I've understood correctly
councelor Parker is is proposing the
office's recommendation as it is online
on on the screen is that right
yeah so we have a proposal we have a
second so we're at that situation where
I'll get the planning manager to read
out what the recommendation is that's
being proposed by councelor Parker and
secondly by councel
register just bear with me
the.gov thing has let me down so I'm
just going to look um oh you got it
there okay thank
you
okay so
um the recommendation is that the
application be
refused as it is proposed new
development within the countryside
contrary to it says emerging here but
contrary to JP policy SBO 3 because
obviously it was changed it was adopted
in between times um the second point is
the proposed development is outside the
settlement boundary poorly connected
does not represent either rural
exception site for aable or Community Le
housing under neighborhood plan policy
Ben
01 thirdd Point does not relate well to
The Villages existing pattern of
development and the new built form
result in the closure of an important
Gap in the streetcape that would be
disrespectful to Historic environment
namely the ire listed Pub the case is
altered which is not considered to be in
accordance with our
policies the fourth point the number of
units sought would overdevelop the site
and in effect elongate the settlement
the existing settlement bound at the
West would then be entirely diluted and
indistinguishable therefore the new
development will diminish the local
distinctiveness of the village by not
paying due regard to the scale form and
nature of adjacent
development uh and therefore does not
comply with policy fifth point the
occupants would have a heavy Reliance
upon motor vehicles um as their main
transport need six the proposed new
vehicle access would require the loss of
Countryside HED R seventh is the lack of
a Rams
contribution and um fin finally it's the
lack of
106 so uh it does say SE here it
shouldn't do that's lack of
106 so it's largely as written on the
report with those errors that I've
pointed out as we' gone through and
changes have we gone through is that
clear are there any doubts at all person
councelor Parker is it clear to you
you're the
proposer that is clear thank you thank
you register you're happy with that yeah
that is clear thank you right
I will now
ask cl to open the electronic vote thank
you chair members that vote is now in
progress so just to remind you you are
voting for or against refusal of the
application uh Council beer may I take
your yes because of condition five I am
against the refusal thank
you councilor
r
all councelor osor are you
having thank
you chair that's 10 votes for refusal
and one against thank you 10 votes for
one against thank you everyone I propose
we have a five minute Comfort break and
that's not time to have a picnic or or
to go and have a coffee spree um and
please can I have you back here no later
than 10 postive open thank
you
um moving on to the next application
it's DC
2347 land between Vicor Lane and tamage
Road Acton suffk um I will now ask the
case officer Elizabeth flood to
introduce the planning application to us
thank you thank you so just before we
start there was a mistake on the
published report does say at the start
refusal that has been changed so if
you're looking at it on the modern gov
it does say approval really sorry about
that um but yeah it is we are
recommending approval for this one um on
that point Mr chairman uh I I'd rather
in the papers and at the end it says
approval and now in Elizabeth she's very
efficient um but who's responsible for
that because when this gets out to the
public they pick these papers up or read
them
pardon absolutely um so if it's a PR and
error that I can understand to find out
for you come back to I signed it off I
didn't spot the error I'm quite sure
it's not the officers at fault but
somewhere along the line This Let The
Establishment down and it and it
shouldn't happen thank
you I signed it off and did not spot
that error counselor beer so it's my
bad yeah it's happened a couple of times
in the last few years but you know yeah
it shouldn't but yes
so this is the site I think you'll
you'll all know it quite well because
it's come to committee at least three
times previously it's the development
for approximately 100 homes uh it
doesn't look like that anymore um
sorry so this is the aerial photograph
this was the last aerial photograph
taken when it was partly being built the
developments all been built out now the
it's fully occupied and the uh developer
has left the site the key things here
are the subs spacin that's the revised
um sub spacin and located here is the
area of public open space and um the
little
um area of uh playground is located in
here the the play
area so again site location plan
that's the constraints there aren't any
constraints really on the
site so this is the key thing previously
when we took it back to a to committee
um a couple of years ago now because
they didn't do the suds spacin in
accordance with the the previous the
approved plans the originally approved
plans uh you as committee agreed that
they could keep their do this slight
slight revision to the um to the s
spacin it would be it could be fenced
off so it wouldn't be part of the public
open space and as compensation the
developer agreed to four extra pieces of
play equipment so this is the play
equipment that was originally approved
and is in place and then these were the
four pieces of additional play equipment
that were proposed and we just included
a condition to uh require details so
that they could change them slightly if
they needed to depending on which
manufacturer and so on um
so this was the approved equipment so
there was a a little climbing frame
another bit more substantial climbing
frame this one had a
slide
then there was a
roundabout and then there was another
sort of climbing net so that was what
was proposed and it was as compensation
for the loss of the play area play um
open space not play area but the open
space within the the
development so since then the developer
no longer wants to do those four pieces
of equipment so what they've asked is to
rary that condition to provide one piece
of gym equipment on the site next to the
existing play area so just here and
you'll see a picture of that so that
would be some sort of electrical bike
yeah I'm sure you you know this sort of
outdoor gym equipment is quite popular
now um and then separate to that they
would also provide another piece of
equipment located here and then one
right at the top of the village uh on
the village playing field and then
separate to that Parish acting parish is
going to put a a fourth piece of
equipment up by the playing field so in
effect you would get a Fitness trail so
you would start here or the other way
around um do some do some exercise then
walk or run to the next one do some more
exercise and then you can go either
route up to the um Sports field um and
then there'll be two pieces of equipment
up
there so again this is just showing it
from aial so the one piece here then
Round Here second piece
here and then round either along sub
Road or along the foot paaths around
here cross over to the um playing area
and then there'll be two pieces
there and also um can't quite see it on
here but the um the the main playing
field for the relig is just yeah you can
just sort of see it it's just down there
next to the primary school so there is
a another playing field sorry another
play area so this is the existing site
you can see the the play area sort of uh
for younger children that was developed
as part of the
site there you go so you can see that
the equipment on here was for very small
children then this is the the land where
the four pieces of equipment were
proposed on the The Wider play area
sorry The Wider public open
space and then this is the site uh
further down the road for the for the
one of the pieces of play equipment as
part of the Fitness
trail and then this is um The Village
Hall is just at the end this is the
cricket ground and then two pieces would
be located here one of which would be
paid for by the
developer and then finally this is the
village playground as it is there's a
Sil bid which I believe is been improved
approved so there will be some more play
equipment up here this is a a really
comprehensive
play area
so um the recommendation is of approval
what we have said is that we
can require the developer to provide the
all three pieces we can't use a section
106 deel agreement because they don't
own the land it's offsite but we feel
that if we use a section 111 agreement
we will have it will give it will be a
contract it's not as strong as the
section 106 agreement
but it would be sufficient to really
hope that the developer does do what
they've said they would do and that that
is a material
consideration um it should be said that
the the Fitness trail although there are
some concerns about it it is what the
parish want they did do an action plan
and one of the things that and they that
action plan they went to the the you
know the public and one of the things
that people asked for was a um a Fitness
trail um so that is what what is
provided so it's a compromise there will
be less on site and so there'll be less
play equipment for the for the people on
the development they've lost some of
their public open space but it will
provide a gym Trail which is what the
parish and certainly some parts of the
community want so with it's it's not a
diff it's not and it's quite well
balanced but we think on balance it's
probably acceptable in this case
um but this is sort of quite exceptional
circumstances it's not something we want
to see very often and it should be said
that there is a small play play area on
the site so we haven't you know it's not
like they haven't provided anything on
site so I think that is everything
really thank you Elizabeth have we any
questions for the
officer councelor Busby um on page 4 one
of your reports um there's a table under
2.9 which talks about costs yeah and the
original proposal the cost of the
developers
22,000 that's what I've estimated okay
and what we're looking at now is 13 and
a half yes either two yes I mean why
don't we just say developer should cough
up 22 Grand and give it to the parish
council and they can buy what they want
where and put it where they like that's
not what's being offered what's been
offered and also the developer has
control over the tamage road so they'd
have to put that one in because they own
that land it doesn't belong to the
parish um what would we've been offered
is is what's in front of you fre pieces
of play equipment yes the developers
probably pleased that they're going to
have to pay less but there are Community
benefits as
well no thank you Elizabeth um we have
no public
speakers other
than councilor melvy as one of the ward
members you have five minutes to address
the committee thank you very much Mr
chairman um in reference to councilor
Beer's comment um about who uh who got
it wrong I would say that to a is human
but to forgive is
divine um this development has been
fraught with difficulties since day one
one um and I'm not going to chew the cut
I'm not going to go over it but this
particular um application has also been
fraught with difficulties and has been
subject to um issues raised by councelor
beer um so I'm here to ensure that it
actually does get passed because it's a
passionate sentiment of Acton Village
that they have what they want they want
a a gym Trail they don't want all the
equipment in one place they want to walk
around the village and exercise while
they're doing leisurely
exercise so I do very much hope that
members will see fit to pass it and we
won't have any more errors and we will
make sure that the right hand talks to
the left hand because that way we save
money and we don't waste time thank
you thank
you are there any
questions no fine then we'll move into
debate anybody like
to councelor beer your turn thank you Mr
chairman well I'm going to um recommend
approval of this application uh I'm all
in favor it's been Ono for a long time
I've heard the comments and Elizabeth
has uh outlined it very very well I
think we're most likely getting the best
deal we can possibly get there and if
you can get the other one thrown in well
you're do even better but uh um and I
have to say the um keep fit
trial uh of items are quite popular we
have some in great cornard and they they
really are popular and I have to say
that's just how I like Cycles
stationary and ones I can sit on and
just pedal around and I don't go
anywhere and if they're electric they're
even better but I know that takes away
from this so I'm quite pleased to move
this uh uh recommendation thank you do I
have a
second counc
Busby thank you do you want to make any
comment or do you think councelor beer
has covered it all for you I mean I
think the concept of a Fitness trail is
alien to most of us but if if the
villagers if that's what they want then
that's good for them thank
you any more comments if not I'll
get the area planning manager to get it
right this
time I have a confession to make I was
the one who discovered
it looking yeah um subject to securing
the proposed section 111
agreement
um get these
out um in terms that are satisfactory to
the chief planning officer that the
application under Section
73 um for dc220
674 um variation of condition one be
approved that is relating to approved
plans and documents and condition four
relating to Plate equipment approved for
the following reasons provision of the
Fitness trail is matal
consideration um which outweighs
paragraph 135 of the
mppf thank you Mark I will now ask
Claire to conduct the vote thank you
chair members that vote is in progress
councelor
beer thank you councelor race thank
you
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for that's
carried meeting will be on the 13th of
December
um and I now formally close the meeting
thank
you
that